did you guys want a hand with some stuff
to mess with you want to keep playing
Basu now we can switch to some other day
so let's get barbara in here gotta get
barbara you got to face her eventually
man you gotta face your fear it doesn't
necessarily have to be barbara there are
other options we could get in there so
maybe maybe fate yeah will be on my side
I got it I got the lobby I've made a
mistake on the rules no you're fine no
it's all good one of the ones you make a
mistake on I unchecked one of the boxes
that you definitely want to checked it
was the third third box yeah okay all
right cool right now I'm good with this
oh hi Barbara wait history right it's
fine yeah it's fine why wouldn't it be
fine it's Barbara seam is fine because
Barbara's a girl hey you don't know
there's plenty of other girl a eyes that
are fine it's because Barbara
single-handedly flippy dippy whippy
targets me and look you just wait she'll
act like she's all nice and happy and
then like you look away for one moment
and there's a poisonous snake biting you
right on the pee-pee parts I okay well I
mean I have yet to see anything that
Barbara does that relates to a poisonous
thing do you switch places your neck
Stewart Bob versus whatever I play
reversed it boom reverse that display
reverse right there I would have done
that to you too extra she's looking
right at me that's the expression on
your toe leader or not hold the door
open just real sick stuff
that's one those are rude but not evil -
she's looking at all of us because she's
inside the remote
who wouldn't hide the remote yeah look
at this evil hand she's got look at this
look she's plotting evil I really feel
like if Barbara was named like Roger you
you wouldn't be as venomous I just don't
you trying to turn this into a sexist
thing I see what you're trying to do no
I mean I'm trying nasty bigoted bait
you doesn't you done messed up waiting I
sure did
see look see you try to take her side
and she still she stabs right in the
booty part why don't I always like the
booty part in the peepee hole I just I
was trying to keep a family friendly
that's the opposite of that
okay well the the underbelly uh-huh is
that better yeah well yeah I guess oh
she really targeted you wait there that
yeah you're the one who suffered in that
situation no no every everything's fine
I'm calm
you guys are calm we're all calm yeah
calm is not you you guys expect her to
do something evil so she's playing it
nice right now
you're walking into the trap I feel like
you are just trying to project because
if anything you've been kind of a douche
hear us Barbara's been nothing but
generous and I've been your friend for
years okay ouch first of all but second
of all point taken
I guess saying friends friends you know
friends listen to each other
friends friends take each other's advice
Barbara's never shunned my advice but I
feel like I feel giving you a lot of hot
tips that have just part 1 part 1
already happened no no that was part
it's good except Bob gave me a plus two
and I didn't go who Bob dude part one
but Barbara did the same thing do you
weigh Bob's a real person with feelings
whoa whoa whoa she's literally sitting
right there whoa I would like those back
if you please
I didn't really think that was how that
was gonna go and I'm glad Barbara's on
board with this yeah Barbara's really
being a fair player she's so receptive
you know become earnestly to Barbara
with an idea with a thought and and she
doesn't she doesn't hold it against you
and she's she's willing to listen wait
you're being really toxic right now and
I feel like you're letting your personal
bias get in the way good job Bob thanks
man well done
I'm happy you won Bob see that just
sounds means that was no Jin that was
legit I'm happy you won Barbara doesn't
win it's a win to me let's see when you
won the last round you were still angry
about it and because she was setting it
up to make me look like the bad guy
ie it's all part of her master plan she
has a master plan okay
I'm getting a little spooky here way
died I feel like you're reading you know
things your your surmising things so
just because she's smart enough to have
a plan you don't like that you don't
like the idea of a lady's not smarting
us against each other I'm comfortable
about this she's I'm trying to be the
things were fine in these parts so
Barbara came along you boys should
really listen to the wise old man it's
the interest of the town I'm literally
requesting ever trying to save your life
experience shame things were fine until
that girl came into town is that what
you're saying yeah Bob came to town
there are plenty of women in the town
that I'm perfectly fine with there's
literally one person I don't like
regardless of sex gender race or
anything else if you want to try to make
me look bad a lot of explaining it for
someone who's actually innocent you know
it's really defensive
you really you really you really went
out there you're like a new station
we're talking about fact I said it
bottom of your relationship with Barbara
and I feel like you're not giving us you
know the truth you're not a clear
picture boom Wolf Lake Trudeau Turbots I
agree with you wait I had probs with
Barbara when I play - no see Barbara
there's there's number one you have
people coming forward telling their
story so the thing is there are
numerous people that are in cells and
they all congregate together it doesn't
mean that they're right given that
there's a lot of them you know what I
mean oh yeah I hear you loud and clear
good job good job I'm glad you won
before she was able to unleash it on us
Arsenal yes that's some strong rhetoric
I feel like that is not helping Thank
You Asian and it's not making you look
good wait say thank you I get to in life
where my friends would turn on me so
easily
Oh what what is what I did yes you did I
do that what happen what happened what
that was very confusing okay well it's a
little early for all these sevens to be
coming out I didn't put anything out but
it was my turn I guess his Barbara
nefariously targeting new wade did she
conspire to create a situation of a
robber took samwell's family away Sam
I've got stories coming in right now so
you want to see you want to see being
targeted Wade I'll show you being
targeted
he's muted not playing I think he has a
plus two we could have crazy dude yeah
there you go
I thought you were just gonna let it
happen well mark I really didn't mean
for doing things to you mom Bob you're
really doing your target hear me yes
pile of cards do you have here look at
how bad that is
I'm not judging you mark I'm judging
your hand Thanks here Bob we're gonna do
a little trade but you got a trade back
okay ready to do the trades no no sorry
wait no this isn't what I wanted
unless you're gonna pile up on Wade
you weighed you underestimated who would
be the most evil at this table all right
Bob you got trade with me you got back
[Music]
[Applause]
wait I think Bob's out to get us
targeting you targeting me you guys are
making light of a serious issue I have
oh and what is this series of you
Barbara and what is Barbara done I
I'm talking to a wall that's you that's
[Laughter]
not challenged that one I'm really sorry
it was it doesn't matter and it's
passing it on I think that you're
targeting barb wow that wasn't really a
partisan that reaction is concerning
Wade yeah the card smell where they lay
but you you really just kick someone
while they were down oh I'll kick and
I'll punch told Barbara's no more okay
that's Lolo that's that aggressive way
too far you're being so toxic right now
your pain is so toxic right now yeah how
did you do that I like this evens it out
for me thanks Barbara bartha's targeting
me to now yeah she's trying to win this
game for herself know what playing these
cards that injured me and you and you to
mark it's just impossible how could she
be so selfish
you're saying we are not on your side
right now wait I feel less slighted as
you do and I feel as abused by this
batch of code as you do yeah brought to
you by the way
that's from Barbara this Barbara Barbara
is doing Barbara did this Barbara's
Orchestra orchestrating I got your back
friend thanks buddy
I'll color you one Bob I'll wait this
time I swear blue is fine I guess well
as a reward for you giving me the color
I wanted okay good
that's what you get for being nice
Barbara got to me she's in my head Oh No
she's controlling my actions now you got
the Barbara virus here let me fix you Oh
Oh No
Oh watch this play that's not watch this
play that's what I meant to do second
chances for good friends here's third
seesaw thank you so much for the second
chance and the third chance the third
Aziz I appreciate you my man you got it
you Wow really Wow are you okay oh and
as much as selfish as Barbara was that
round and as ruthless that she was
coming after us somehow you managed to I
still pulled out the victory yeah so we
all do Shaylee Wade we all live she knew
all right I walked right into her trap
what is happening nothing with that for
you who are you happening what get a
bond you don't have it's a good hand
wait I want you to have that one all
right thank you see it's good see what I
gave you it's pretty good
no Barbara's doing it again no it's mind
game the mind games are real - it's for
reals for reals yeah it seems like she's
being nice and helping everyone except
herself but I see we call her out you
guys understand mm-hmm we're on your
side man I'm fully behind you right now
don't meet yourself I'm on their side
right here I'm trying trying to be a
friend right now
oh wow changing the color like that Oh
Mike don't yes don't condescend let's
let's take Wade side and see what I see
how open my eyes and I look at Barbara
with judgmental truths exercise and I
will I will look at her only for her
being a a woman and nothing else I swear
to god I'm actually on your side way
don't worry about it behind me you are
the worst what did i do what did i do
I'm looking through your eyes if you say
I'm the worst then you're really
painting a picture about yourself has
zero to do with his artificial
intelligences assigned gender through
the person who created this infernal
Decker
all right so what is it then the way
it's the mental it's the mind the
mastermind no it's the ish wait yeah
that's it you racist you racist I want
you to go next so I'm gonna I don't want
him to go next I just tried to be on
your side way Barbro thank you very much
you calm down with Thank You Barbara
Thank You Barbara finally I get to get
revenge wait this is for you wait a
minute Bob thank you that counts but all
right we're not counting that right now
tell you what Bob you helped me outta
your pale green oh you actually did
green yeah yeah is this what it feels
like to have a friend dude I'm your
friend that's why I'm calling you out
goofed on me knowdon't you didn't do the
color I said you asked me and then you
didn't even wait that was so mean then I
flipped it back
one you liked about it you're reading
really Barbara about this Bob Oh sounds
like you know what wait I think you were
right the whole time I think you suck it
you were right the whole time I think
you were wrong both of you and I think
mark has teamed up with Barbara oh is
this what a team-up would do oh that's
what yeah your betrayal gets you yeah I
don't associate with racists that's just
a blanket statement I'm not accusing
anybody I don't associate with them
that's good for you oh you're still
being a real turd right now Oh dirt
burglars Oh turns I wouldn't steal your
turds if you had the last turds on earth
it's still my turn so hard right now
good night don't you know what you're
doing you know what you did you're doing
it right now
I don't want your doing smell what the
mark is cooking I've known away I don't
remember what that does okay it's that
one we all know the truth part of the
car it's part of the cards here are the
cards what so what if Barbara gets a
good wind my cards is that doing it why
would you look at my yeah that was
dead-on then what do you copy in my
settings over there yeah that's what I'm
gonna do I'm stealing your clout Oh your
cloud is mine and your Therese you see
how mark has turned against the we're
all we're all fighting against it's all
partner plan I think marks going senile
I think mark forgot how this were I know
and he's younger than me Wow my time is
limited on this planet it's a real turd
burglar not my teammates you know who's
Berglund turds right now
you can check I don't have any turds I
don't think that's the truth
oh you check check me check all my
pocket how would I check if you stole
interns you could have buried them
anymore but you wouldn't know where you
like to bury things well okay and want
that to happen yours
that's you really don't it's not it's
not gonna be easy to do this I'm
concerned about okay oh well I guess
that's happening it's read she did read
and read again well I bet you hear some
read you've read or read for you that's
such a turd burglar turns to me turds
ever take some of that how's that turd
smell that was more of a fart burglar
move those are pretty similar gas in a
solid play this whole game all the way
around yeah get her weighed what
happened on your side the whole time
yeah Marcus piles on finally is pointed
to something going on here listen you
know you know me work we've been since
the start I'm on the year side of this
whole Barbara situation your raps gonna
take this Bob you convinced me
well here take some of this such a
Barbara thing to do hey don't you dare
insult my girl really save mark there
huh yeah don't want anyone to have any
fun I'm the real Barbara here you will
never be as good as Barbara two nights
in a row so suspicious suspect away I
think so get them again Bob
no you green or blue Bob green or blue
green you got it oh how that works
let's just see what happens part of the
cards because otherwise if you drop for
me after I've doubled rod for you well
let's see what the heart of the cards
gives me Bob a lot yeah help my friend
win uh here are we called me his friend
yeah just let fate decide what happens
to my cards it's a little your turn
right now no wonder how many cards he's
gonna draw this time I'm sorry what
oh he's been disconnected what happened
you kicked me I don't know you're
talking I hate you 3,000 look what is
Barbara ever done me Barbara didn't want
win
bob was the one that kept nailing you
hard and fast mark I think you're
forgetting I'm the nice one so oh yeah
you know what you know what you're right
you're right you are the nice one that's
true I never do anything mean you've
never done you know our life yeah so
clearly I've never known you'd be mean
in any way shape or form yes is it
because Globox is a man that you're
suddenly like oh yeah to call Globox a
man for fair look at the masculine Jolla
I'm supposed to do a thing look at the
masculine jawline look at the huge penis
mark do you act like a sexual things you
want to do you want to come out and say
something this is self commentary and
you're learning through your hatred of
me about how you feel about different
genders yes take these cards and think
about that answer to that yes because
let's do it call box you big hulking man
take that weight out for you mark did
that to you I never forget yeah mark did
that to you I did that to you mark did
you catch me I just but it was
legitimate like even I was like yeah I
did that to you but bla that was all
your fault mark did that to you wait did
you catch that at all we in the same
mindset as me like it wasn't totally
over my head you don't really pay
attention to that source
[Laughter]
okay all right well those situations
where I'm not gonna catch any heat for
something if I see an opportunity to
show discord between us I just chuck it
out there hey I just want to see what
happens if I let that if I let a little
bit more randomness and chaos
hey mark Globox my own secret friends
right wait buddy I'm on your side you
can trust me haha that's not that
doesn't make me feel good it shouldn't
yeah that's a lot I did I did I'm just
gonna take all the cards I did this to
you don't worry this will soon be
someone else's hand yeah you right
you're right it sounds like this world
like if I get you because I take
ownership every Bob wait a minute now
you'll have to chat now you have to go
scour all the videos no wait what the
hell I don't think yeah I don't think
you did no I hit it before you and put
the card out what no I don't think you
did I doesn't want you to win no I but I
hit it way before I put the card out and
then there was no even after tell mark
why this one to yourself no that's not
fair you played yourself oh these must
play myself I think you did you didn't
click you know and I got you I just
clicked you know
and it counted because I'm normal okay
it didn't work before did you really
just do that I look I'm trows do we need
to try to prove a point but listen game
no I I clicked it uh-huh you know Bob's
been winning a lot of Matt Bob Bob wah
uh-huh yeah okay wait keep going yeah
yeah
is gone all right I see where you know
my dots here yeah are you saying that
right now Bob for some reason I still
want you to win cuz I feel like I'm
being played here pretty hard we are
friends we are friends marks the one
who's a jerk
don't let it know so two Reds I've got
wow that was harsh
I don't want to feel your dick radial
wait why do you do that to people you
sack of
it was you stole my hand you literally
see there's no other Reds there yeah
that's mark mark said that yeah I did
minou I forget who were making fun of
right now
you're so busy pointing fingers you have
no idea where the conversation every
other direction oh snap thanks for
changing it from red I appreciate that
you're welcome in your well he just
played the same draw that I guess it's
not a draw for us so that's fine thanks
bud you're welcome bud it's teamwork
alright what's happening you're it's
your play bud but it's not letting me do
anything I it's so weird that when the
game doesn't work for no reason
what's the problem you can't play any
cards what we did Wade like did that
storm finally knock Wade out or
something I mean I'm here oh oh yeah
it's definitely Wade's fault I think
you're right no I'm legitimately like my
hand is grayed out
that's how weird I can't draw card can't
play any cards huh Bob I know you have
nothing to do with this but why are you
being like I have nothing to do with it
that's exactly right
wait a minute wait now sir just know I
know there's no way you have nothing to
do with this but yeah I have nothing to
do with it obviously that's why I'm just
saying it's so weird that you can't play
any cards right now it's just out of
nowhere it's so random yeah yeah it is
it and the timer hasn't popped up I I
guess it's a glitch in the matrix Sergio
god I can't even leave i just opened the
menu it
the menu anymore sounds like it's on
sounds like it's on hit escape I could
not possibly have anything to do with no
I'm agreeing with you i'm i alt F for it
you know mark I really wish you'd just
play Cardon quit goofing around am I
still there for you guys yeah I'm uh I'm
dying my stream is dying I knew it I
knew it was you so it's so weird that
your that your sign is dropping when I
just dropped 31,000 frames out of
nowhere oh that's not so much connection
is read I think the storm is taking me
down film it markiplier is no longer
here alright the game is happening yeah
wait if you die film it
[Music]